-My first guest tonight is
an Emmy- and
Golden Globe-winning actor.
She directed and stars in
the new movie "Moxie,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
You have to watch it.
It is so good.
Here is Amy Poehler!
Ah, that's what
I'm talking about.
See? Ah, I missed you, buddy.
So good to see you.
-Hi! Hi, Jimmy.
I'm so happy to be here.
-I want to get into "Moxie"
and what a great job
you did directing that.
But it was so great to see you
hosting the Golden Globes.
You were fantastic.
You were so funny.
You looked great.
But I know, from hosting
these awards shows,
it is a lot of work.
I can't imagine what it was like
hosting one during a pandemic.
-Yeah, you know what it's like.
There's a lot of things
that can go wrong.
And I had -- It was interesting,
'cause I had, like,
new stress dreams.
You know, usually,
your dreams are that
you're going to, you know,
say the wrong thing
or you're gonna, you know, fall.
But I kept having these, like,
technological stress dreams
that, you know,
was just going to disappear.
Just like bloop!
-Like, bad edit-- Like,
the audio going out or something
or people cutting
to the wrong camera?
-Mm! All those.
Like, basically like
a living Zoom nightmare
is what I was having.
-But it was kind of --
It was like a Kubrick film,
because every -- The audience
was masked and quiet
and spread out
and just kind of staring at us.
-Wowsers.
It's a lot, a lot,
a lot of work.
And, man, I can't --
On behalf of everyone who saw
it, thank you so much.
Like a lot of people
during this past year,
I've heard that
you've gotten into TikTok.
Is that right?
-Yeah. Big-time.
-Whoa!
-Big Tok.
-Talk to me.
-Big-time.
-Really?
-Well, you know what
I do like about it a lot?
Is that I like that it takes
an idea, audio,
and it kind of --
You know, like,
people just decide how they're
going to deconstruct something.
And so I like that, you know,
a joke just keeps getting done
and then change into
something else
or the pastiche of it all.
Someone takes someone's audio
and someone's video
and then comments.
-It just, like --
It feels very D.I.Y.
And then, speaking of
the Golden Globes,
I saw La'Ron Hines,
the great, sweet La'Ron Hines,
who is, like, a TikTok star,
dare I say.
And he interviews kids at his
mom's daycare in Mississippi.
And we ended up having him
on the Golden Globes.
-Isn't that cool?
That's amazing that you --
I loved that part.
That was great. That's wild.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-I did --
I'm doing more TikToks.
But I did my first one,
and I want to say it
took me like three hours to do.
I go...
-Yeah, I don't do any.
I don't do any.
I don't.
I don't add any value to TikTok.
I just watch it and go,
"Good for him.
She's right."
-Right?
That's good.
You got to love it.
-I'm like, "Oh, that's what
that button does."
Stuff like that.
That's what TikTok
helps me with.
"Oh, that's how
I can clean my sink."
-Yeah! That's what I --
Dude, I love the hacks.
-Show me a better way
to fold my chip bag,
and you got me for life.
-Dude, what's this thing
about frying cheese?
I never knew that you -- If you
fry cheese, like, really thin,
you can use that as kind of
like the bread almost.
-Oh, boy, that's gonna --
-No, it's insane.
I've already --
I was just watching it.
-What if I just --
I immediately ran out of frame,
and you started -- You heard the
sizzling sound of cheese.
-Look, I know you as a great
comedian, a writer, an actor.
And I know you directed,
but now you directed
your second movie, "Moxie."
It is on Netflix now.
It is fantastic.
And I just want to say
I love it,
because I have two girls now.
And I don't know -- I'm also a
coming-of-age-movie fan.
But I don't know if
there is a movie
that's kind of like this movie,
that's for girls, where --
It's for everybody,
I mean, but I feel like
there's nothing out there
for my girls to watch
where they go like,
"Oh, yeah,
that's an awesome message."
That is so cool.
I just loved it.
I thought it was well-done,
top to bottom.
-Thank you very much.
I mean, we grew up
with the same movies, right?
So, I always loved those
high-school movies that had,
you know, kind of
the quiet female protagonist,
like Molly Ringwald,
if you will,
who was watching the action
and trying to figure out
how to participate in it.
And, you know, the book that it
was based on is, you know,
written by
a high-school teacher.
And we really wanted it
to feel like
what high school feels like --
high stakes, big feelings.
-It really is high stakes.
I mean, when you're --
especially when
you're in high school.
It's like, you don't --
Now we're older,
I don't think about that,
but you're like,
"Oh, no, no, this is
the biggest thing in the world."
-Oh, big-time.
I mean I have a feeling
you and I
had very similar
high-school experiences.
I mean, I don't know about you,
but I had a big high school,
lots of different groups.
-Yeah.
-You really had to kind of
declare who you were.
There was a lot of lists.
Like, a lot of superlatives --
like,
inappropriate superlatives.
-Yeah, I'm trying to think of
what I can even say anymore.
But yeah.
-I know, you can't.
Like, I know we had, like,
Class Flirt
and Best Couple
and Best Eyes and Cutest.
And it was like, "God!
Why don't you just put Nice Rack
on there and call it a day."
[ Both laugh ]
-That's what I won!
-You got Nice Rack?!
-Yeah, in high school.
That was me.
-Congratulations!
-Thank you. I was excited.
I'll take what
I can get, though.
-You had a really nice rack
on your car,
on the top of your car?
-Like, horns and stuff.
It wasn't real animal,
of course.
-Yeah, it was a nice rack.
It should win.
-Can you tell everyone
what "Moxie" is about?
-Sure. So, it's -- "Moxie"
is about a 16-year-old girl
who is trying to figure out how
she fits into her high school.
She has a mom who is a more
extroverted, rebel-girl past.
And she doesn't know how
to speak up
and speak out against the things
that are bothering her
and that are dangerous
in her school.
So she gets inspired by a zine
and she makes one
and she leaves it in her school.
And it's taken over by
the other women in the school.
And together, they try to
bring the system down.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Amy Poehler in
her new movie, "Moxie."
Take a look at this.
-Me and my friends,
we protested everything.
One time, someone told
our friend Sarah
that she smelled, and none of us
showered for two weeks.
[ Both laugh ]
Yeah.
-But how do you know what to do,
like, how to protest something?
-We didn't.
You know,
we made a ton of mistakes.
We argued with each other.
We weren't
intersectional enough.
We called our meetings pow-wows.
-Oh, no.
-Mm-hmm.
-But you're glad
you did it all, right?
-Of course.
What are you going to do?
Nothing?
-Amy Poehler, everybody!
"Moxie" is streaming now
on Netflix.
By the way, congrats on it being
the number-1 movie
on Netflix, bud.
That's the way to do it.
-How cool?
-That is the way to do it,
Amy Poehler!